pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieux vous savez ce que c'est une
coquille d'huître qui ne va pas me
servir à vous parler de l'origine de ce
coquillage menuau ostracisme
une attitude qui consiste à exclure un
individu ou un groupe
ostracisme vient du grec
austra quand je sais ça ne s'invente pas
même si je le prononce à la française un
mot qui signifie au sens propre du terme
coquilles d'huîtres mais quel rapport
entre la mise à l'écart d'un individu et
la coquille
le terme ostracisme a été utilisée dès
le 5e siècle avant notre ère dans la
grèce antique lors des assemblées
publiques
on votait le bannissement temporaire
d'une personne considérée dangereuse
pour la cité et citoyens inscrivaient
leur grotte c'est une coquille comme
celle ci l'ostracisme signifie donc que
le verdict par les huîtres l'histoire ne
raconte pas si avant de voter on les
déguste elle tient à la question faut-il
manger des huîtres avec du pain et du
beurre
moi je vote oui si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus merci les épis curieux pour les
plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]